The third myth about microkernel based design is
that the thread switches and inter process communication
can be very expensive. And by thread switch
we mean, if you are executing one thread
in a particular protection domain and going to
execute another thread in a different protection domain,
how much time does it take for this
thread switch to be effected by the microkernel,
that's the question that we're asking here. Here
again, we're only talking about the explicit cost of
doing the thread switching. And the explicit cost that
is involved in thread switching, is saving all the
volatile state of the processor, the T1 thread
that is running on the processor. It's modified the
registers of the CPU. All of that has to
be stashed away in the thread context block before
we can schedule the second thread to run on the processor. The cost that we're
talking about is saving all the volatile state
of the processor. And what L3 does is
once again, by construction, it shows that the thread switch time in L3
microkernel is as competitive as SPIN and exokernel. So,
once again by construction, L3 debunks that myth that microkernel
based OL structure is going to be more expensive for thread switching
compared to SPIN or exokernel or even a monolithic operating system.